[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا على هذه الحلقه الجديده
من مستقبل الطاقه هذه ملفاتنا
مع بوادر الاتفاق الاوروبيه على سقف لسعر
الخام الروسي ما الخيارات امام اجتماع
اوبن بلس الاحد
[موسيقى]
وفي ظل نقص الديزل والبنزين في اوروبا
الفرصه تلوح لمصافي الشرق الاوسط
يوم الاحد
بالرغم من ابداء الولايات المتحده
انزعاجها الشديد من السعوديه جرائم قرار
اوبك بلس في اكتوبر الماضي خفض الانتاج
بواقع مليونير برميل يوميا ولكن يبدو ان
الوقائع على الارض مستمره في تاكيد صحه
هذا القرار فاسعار خام برنت وصلت انخفاضها
لتفقد مكاسب كل السنه الحاليه لتقارب عتبه
الثمانين دولار للبرميل مؤخرا وياتي ذلك
بسبب تدهور سوره الطلاق في الصين حيث يبدو
ان تخارج الصين من سياسه صفر كوفد لن تكون
سلسه في ظل ارتفاع حالات الاصابات الى
مستويات قياسيه واستياء السكان في بعض
المدن من الاجراءات الاحترازيه واحتجاجهم
عليها بالتالي تدهور النظر المستقبليه
للطلب اضافه الى موسم صيانه مصافي التكرير
المقبله بين فبراير الى ابريل كلها عوامل
سلبيه قد تدفع تحالف اوبك في النظري خياري
اقراري خفض اضافي في الانتاج في اجتماعه
المقبل يوم الاحد الرابع من ديسمبر حيث
المح البيان الصادر عن وزير الطاقه
السعوديه الاسبوع الماضي الى ان المجموعه
مستعده لاتخذه تخفيضات اضافيه في الانتاج
اذا دعت الحاجه لاعاده التوازن ما بين
العرض والطلب لكن ومع تغيير المجموعه
الاجتماعي المقبل من اجتماع حضوري الى
افتراضي قبل ايام يبدو بالتالي ان اوبن
بلس اقرب لتمديد العمل بسقف الانتاج
الحالي
وذلك الى حين اتضح الصوره بشكل افضل في
اسواق النفط خاصه في ظل الاستحقاقات
الهامه المقبله فاجتماع اوبيك بلاس المقبل
ينعقد قبل يوم واحد فقط من بدء تطبيق
الاتحاد الاوروبي للجوله السادسه من
العقوبات على روسيا والتي تشمل هذه المره
حذرا اورو على استيراد الخام الروسي عبر
الناقلات اضافه الى منع تقديم خدمات
التامين والشحن الاوروبيه لاي شحنه خام
روسيه مهما كانت وجهتها هذه الاجراءات
ستتزامن مع فرض سقف سعري على صادرات الخام
الروسي اقرته مجموعه السبع
فدول غرب تريد خفض ايرادات روسيا النفطيه
ولكن في نفس الوقت ضمان استمرار تدفق
امداداتها الى السوق كي لا تصعد اسعار
النفط فاذا كانت شحنه ما من الخام الروسي
تم شرائها تحت هذا السقف بالتالي الشحنه
مؤهله للحصول على خدمات الشحن والتامين من
الشركات الاوروبيه
ولكن هناك صعوبات في ايجاد توافق الاوروبي
حول مستوى هذا السقف لانه اذا كان السقف
السعري منخفض جدا هذا حتما سيدفع روسيا
لرفض بيع خامها لاي دوله مشاركه في هذا
السقف من شانه خفض الامدادات في السوق ولا
ننسى بان الصين والهند قد رفضتا المشاركه
في السقف السعري حتى الان وفي ظل تلك
المعطيات وقعت وكاله الطاقه الدوليه
انخفاض الانتاج النفط الروسي العام المقبل
بنحو 15% لكن العوامل المتغيره عديده وكل
التوقعات السابقه بحدوث انخفاض حاد في
الانتاج الروسي هذا العام لم تتحقق بالرغم
من العقوبات المتزايده
بالرغم من الضبابيه الحاليه التي تعيشها
السوق النفطيه بات مؤكدا ان التحالف
بقياده السعوديه سينتهج المسلك المتحفظ
ويلزم الحيطه والحذر الى حين وضوح الرؤيا
فلن يتم تمديد المكاسب التي تم تحقيقها
على صعيد استقرار السوق خلال السنتين
الماضيتين لاسيما في ضوء الجهود الجباره
والتكلفه العاليه التي تحملها اعضاء
التحالف وعلى راسهم السعوديه
[موسيقى]
اذا مساله فرض سقف سعر من قبل مجموعه
السبع على صادرات الخام الروسيه هو نوع
جديد من العقوبات لم يتم استخدامه من قبل
وبالتالي هناك الكثير من الاسئله المتعلقه
باليه فرضه ما هي محددات مستوى هذا السقف
هل سيكون هناك توافق حوله من الدول التي
ستفرده وهل ستقبل بتطبيقه كبرى الدول
المستهلكه وما هي اليه تطبيقه هذه الاسئله
وغيرها وشاهتها الى كبير محلليه النفط
الخام في انرجي اسبكس كريستوفر هينز
وبدانا بمناقشه مستوى السقف السعر المقترح
مبدئيا والذي يتراوح ما بين ال 65 الى 70
دولار للبرميل
يا امين
[موسيقى]
فحس من السعر في السوق بل انه اعلى من
السعر الحالي لخام اليورول في السوق حيث
وصلت الخصومات على خام اليوراني الى نحو
30 دولار للبرميل مقابل خام برنت برنتو
تداول اليوم قرب 80 دولارا ما يعني ان
السعر السوقيه الحالي اليوراني اللي هو
اعلى من 50 دولار بقليل لكن الامر الاخر
الذي علينا اخذه بالاعتبار عند التفكير
بالسقف السعري هو ان روسيا لا تصدر
اليوراني بل تصدر عددا من الخامات الاخرى
كذلك مثل خاماتها المنتجه من القصب
الشمالي مثلا وتلك الخامات تتداول اسعارها
اليوم عند مستويات اعلام خام اليورو حتى
لذاع علينا ان ننتظر لنرى كيف سيتم تصميم
اليه هذا سقف السعر لكن حاليا وفي ضوء
تداول خامراء دون مستوى السقف المقترح فان
السقف السعر لن يغير الكثير ولكن في حاله
عاودت اسعار النفط ارتفاعها واتجاهها برنت
نحو 100$ في حينها سقف فريق قد يصبح محل
شك لان روسيا ستكون قادره على البيع خارج
هذا السقف وتحقيق ارباح اعلى
صادرات الخام الروسيه امرا قابلا للتنفيذ
والتطبيق على ارض الواقع ام انه سيكون
اجراءا عقابيا ولكن من دون مخالب حقيقيه
على سن قانون لا يجيز لاي شركه الروسيه
بالسقف السعري ولكننا نفطر روسي سيجد
طريقه الى الاسواق عبر مواني روسيا
الاوروبيه فالحظروا الاوروبي سيكون واقعه
اكبر على روسيا من واقع السقف السري لان
الحضره سيوقف صدرات روسيا الى اوروبا اما
السقف الساري فسيجعل العديد من الدول
الاخرى وشركاتها تفكر مرتين قبل التعامل
الروسيه
احتماليه الاوروبيه او امريكيه وهذا خطر
كبير لا تريد بعض الشركات ان تتعرضه
كريستوفر على نفس هذه النقطه هل ممكن
لجوله العقوبات الاوروبيه السادسه على
روسيا والتي تستهدف حظر خدمات الشحن
والتامين عن الصادرات النفطيه الروسيه ان
يتم تطبيقها من دون تطبيق سقف سعري
[موسيقى]
سيجعل الامر اكثر صعوبه الجوله السادسه من
العقوبات الاوروبيه تم تصميمها من دون
فكره السقف السعدي في بادئ الامر هذه
الفكره تم طرحها من قبل الامريكيين بهدف
الابقاء على تدفق جزء اكبر من الامدادات
الروسيه الى السوق فعلينا الا ننسى بان
السوق الامريكيه من مكتشفه اكثر من
الاوروبيه على تقلبات اسعارها لان نسبه
الضرائب فيها اقل من اوروبا
عالميا سيؤثر اكثر على المستهلك الامريكي
مقارنه بالاوروبي ومن ناشده اليوم هو خلاف
في الاراء حول هذا السقف لانه ما يحرك
الاوروبيين للانضمام الى السقف الساري هو
الحجم الكبير نسبي لقطاع الشحن البحري في
دول مثل اليونان ومالطه وقبرص والتي تعتمد
اقتصادتها كثيرا عليها
[موسيقى]
بالتالي ما هي توقعاتكم لحجم الانخفاض
المرتقب للانتاج وللصادرات الروسيه في ضوء
العقوبات المقترحه
الاولى من العقوبات الاوروبيه في الخامس
من ديسمبر المقبل على صدره الخام الروسيه
لن نشهد لها اثرا فورا وذلك لان الخام
الروسي سيتم تحميله كما العاده على
الناقله وسيتم شحنه ولكن الى اسواق جديده
حول العالم ولكن المشكله الاكبر ستكون في
الخامس من فبراير المقبل عندما يتم فرض
الحظر على صدرات المشتقات النفطيه الروسيه
فهناك مصاف روسيه تعمل على تصدير الديزل
والفيو اويل وتحديدا الى الاسواق
الاوروبيه وعندما يدخل هذا الحظر حيز
التنفيذ سيكون من الصعب جدا لروسيا ان تجد
اسواقا لان السوق الاوروبيه دائما ما
تواجه شحا في هذا النوع من المشتقات فيهن
ان باقي العالم دائما ما يكون لديه
امدادات كافيه من الديزل الحظر على
المشتقات قد يخفض انتاج روسيا بنحو مليون
يوميا
كريستوفر هل هذا الرقم الانخفاض في
الانتاج ام في الصادرات الروسيه
ستضغط على الانتاج الروسي من الخامس ولكن
صادرات المشتقات ايضا ستنخفض بضع مئات
الالاف البراميل يوميا ايضا ولكن بعد مرور
عده اشهر على تلك العقوبات ستتضح الصوره
اكثر حول من هي الاطراف المرتاحه لاستلام
النفط الروسي ومن هي الاطراف التي ستجد
صعوبه في ذلك وهل سنرى ضروره اكبر لاسطول
الناقلات الذي يعمل خارج المنظومه لنقل
هذا النفط المنظر عده اسابيع كان هناك بعض
الاشارات الى ان الصين قد تبدا في تخفيف
اجراءتها الاحترازيه المرتبطه بكرونا لكن
ارقام الاصابات اليوميه في تصاعد سريع
ووصلت الى مستويات قياسيه جديده بالتالي
ما هي توقعاتكم للطلب الصيني خلال الاشهر
المقبله
برنامج
يضغط على اسعار النفط فاذا نظرت الى عدد
من المؤشرات الرئيسيه كاحجام النفط
المتدفق نحو الصين حاليا فانها تنخفض بشكل
حالي وهذا مؤشر بان مصافي التكرير الصينيه
لديها كميات مريحه من المخزون مع اقتراب
نهايه العام حيث ما يتم شرائه اليوم هو
لتسليم شهر فبراير وما سينتج عن ذلك هو
ارتفاع اكبر في المخزونات الصينيه مع
اقتراب نهايه العام الحالي بسبب ضعف الطلب
المحلي هناك لكن تلك المخزونات ستعود
للتراجع في شهرين
مع تراجع حجم الوالده وهذا شيء سيتابعه
لان السوق الصيني سوق مهم جدا بالنسبه له
لكن بكل تاكيد اعتقد بان طلب الصيني ضعيف
جدا في الوقت الراهن
كريستوفر في ضوء هذه المعطيات هل تتوقعون
محافظه اوبك على قرارها السابق بخفض
الانتاج بمليوني برميل يوميا خلال
الاجتماع القادم في الرابع من ديسمبر
خلالها بتقييم كل العوامل في السوق منها
انتهاء صلاحيه عقود الشهر المقبل حيث
بالامكان ان نرى بعض التغييرات عندما ندخل
في عقود فبراير لكن بشكل رئيسي اذا ما
نظرنا الى سبب قيام اوبك بلس بالحفظ
الاخير في انتاجها فسجد بان ضعف اساسيات
السوق الصينيه هي التي دفعتهم الى ذلك فلا
ننسى ان الصين هي اكبر سوق بالنسبه لهم
واذا ما لمسه مؤشرات على عدم قيام مصر في
تكرير الصينيه بالشراء منهم فهذا يعطيهم
مؤشرا واضحا على صحه الطلب هناك بالتالي
من عملائهم في الصين سيكون خير دليل على
حقيقه الوضع هناك وهذا قد يدفعهم الى
اتقاء الانتاج عند مستويات الحاليه او حتى
يقرر يخفض صغير ليستبرق السوق ويدعموها
بعض الشيء امرا اخر يشكل
انخفاضه وقود الشهر المقبل مقارنه باسعار
العقود المستقبليه الابعاد هذه
تشكل حافظا للشركات لملئ خزاناتها واوبك
تكره هذه الحاله بشده لذا من الاكيد بانهم
سينظرون الى هيكليه السوق السعريه والى
الطالب الصيني بشكل دقيق جدا قبل ان
يتخذوا قرارهم ان شاء الله
كل ما سبق هل المخاطر سعوديه ام نزوليه
على سعر النفط ونحن مقبلون على السنه
الجديده
[موسيقى]
قبل ذلك في الرابع من ديسمبر لدينا
اجتماعه
حسنه ومؤثره للسوق وستمتد ذيولها الى
العام المقبل
فمثلا اذا ارادت اوبك خفت انتاجها فهذا
سيبدا في يناير وقد التزامنه هذا مع فقدان
بعض الصادرات الروسيه في حال لم تجد
اسواقا بديله وهذا سيضغط على امدادات
السوق لذا الكثير يعتمد على تلك الامدادات
وعلى الطالب الصيني كذلك نحن نتوقع اعاده
فتح النشاط الاقتصادي الصيني بشكل اقوى
بدءا من الربع الثاني من العام المقبل اي
بعد انتهاء موسم الشتاء المقبل ما يعني
باننا قد نرى عمليه شراء اقوى على عقود
شهر مارس بدءا من شهر يناير القادم
بالتالي قد نجد شحا اكبر في الامدادات مما
يتوقعه البعض الى جانب تحسن صوره الطلب من
الربع الثاني لذا في نظري فان المخاطر
التي سيشهدها سعر النفسيه مخاطر السعوديه
خلال الاشهر المقبله
[موسيقى]
يتوقف مفاصل قصير نتابع بعده في مستقبل
الطاقه
دراسه كابسه بالارقام كيف ساعدت قردات
قرارات اوبيك بلس في استقرار اسواق النفط
[موسيقى]
النقص في امدادات الوقود مثل الديزل
والبنزين الذي يواجه اوروبا والولايات
المتحده في ضوء سعيهم لانهاء اعتمادهم على
المشتقات الروسيه يشكل فرصه سامحه لمصاف
التكرير العملاقه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
والتي قامت بزياده حجم قدراتها التكريريه
في السنوات الماضيه بينما توجه الدول
الغربيه الى خفضها فما بين عام 2019 الى
20 21 انخفضت قدرات التكرير في اوروبا
وامريكا بنحو مليونين و400.000 برميل
يوميا بينما اضاف الشرق الاوسط واسيا في
نفس الفتره ما يقرب من مليونين ونصف
المليون برميل يوميا ويبدو ان هذه الفجوه
في القدرات التكريه بين الشرق والغرب
مرشحه للازدياد فالتقديرات تشير الى ان
العالم سيضيف خلال سنوات الثلاث المقبله
ما يق من ثمانيه ملايين برميل يوميا من
قدرات التكرير الجديده ومن المتوقع ان ال
90% من تلك الاضافات الجديده سيتم بنائها
في الشرق الاوسط واسيا
فمصافي الشرق الاوسط ستقوم بتكرير ما يصل
الى 8.8 مليون برميل يوميا من الخام خلال
عام 20 23 بحسب وكاله الطاقه الدوليه ما
يعد نموا بنحو مليون برميل يوميا عن
مستويات ما تم معالجته عام 2019 ما سيسمح
بلا شك بتصدير كميات اكبر من الوقود الى
دول اوروبا التي تعاني من نقص في القدرات
التكريريه وتواجه مخاطر امن الوقود في
معضله تشح المشتقات النفطيه في اوروبا
وتحديدا من الديزل مرشحه لمزيدا من التازم
خلال الاشهر القليله المقبله في ظل توجه
الاتحاد الاوروبي لحضر استيراد كافه
المشتقات النفطيه الروسيه عبر الناقلات
البحريه بدءا من مطلع فبراير المقبل
[موسيقى]
قرارات اوبك بلس كانت دائما محل جدا حول
تاثيرها على الاسواق لكن دراسه لمركز
الملك عبد الله للدراسات البتروليه كابسر
كشفت بالارقام ان قرارات اوبك بلس سواء
بزياده الانتاج او تخفيضه قللت من تذبذب
اسعار النفط بشكل كبير اذا انها تحد من
ارتفاع الاسعار في فترات معينه وتحد من
انخفاضها في فتره اخرى وهذا هو معنى تحقيق
الاستقرار في الاسواق للمتابع
لطالما اثبتت الوقائع صحه قرارات اوبيك
بلاست التي تتخذها للمحافظه على التوازن
الاسواق واستقرارها في مواجهه المتغيرات
على الساحه الاقتصاديه العالميه
والبحوث البتروليه
كشفت ان اداره اوبيك بلاستي طاقتها
الانتاجيه الفائضه قلل من تقلبات اسعار
النفط لنحو 50% خلال الفتره من يناير 2017
وحتى اغسطس 2001
بلس متوسطه الاسعار بمقدار دول رينو ونصف
الدولار
ارتفع متوسطه الاسعار من 18 دولارا الى
54$
ويشهد قطاع النفط منذ عقود طويله صدمات
كبيره ومتكرره في العرض والطلب لاسباب
منها الحروب وادي صوت طبيعيه والتغيرات في
النمو الاقتصاديه وغيرها تقلبات تؤثر على
اسعار النفط التي تعد مصدرا لتكاليف
الاقتصاديه التي يتحملها المستهلكون
والمنتجون ويتخذ بعضها شكل الصدمات في
الاقتصاد العالمي وتؤثر على الارادات
والاستثمارات وخطط الانتاج ومع حدوث اي من
الصدمات في اسواق النفط فهو يتطلب تعديلا
كبيرا نسبيا للاسعار لاستعاده التوازن
وتحقيق الاستقرار لاثاره الايجابي على
الاقتصاد العالمي فقد اثبت الدراسه لاوبيك
انها تقدها الانتاجيه الفائده رفعت من
الناتج المحلي العالمي 200 مليار دولار
سنويا
يعني هذا مشاهدينا نصل الى ختام هذه
الحلقه من مستقبل الطاقه دائما تابعونا
على تويتر تحت وسم هاشتاج مستقبل الطاقه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]